the endings of eldon ring are tricky
from software likes leaving things up to
interpretation that lets each player
create their own story out of their own
playthrough that also means that each
ending is going to have some sort of
justification saying why it's the good
one though i think if we look at the
themes and motivations of the game and
what kind of experience the game is
designed to bring about we can find an
ending that matches up with those themes
we can determine which ending is best
so eldon ring has six endings in total
but four of those are variants of the
same ending so it only gives
achievements for the three main endings
the elden lord the age of the stars and
the lord of frenzied flame
at this point i want to note that we
need to understand what happens in each
ending before we can determine which is
best so if you haven't watched my video
explaining all six endings i'd recommend
you go do that now and those of you that
have watched that video can probably
guess which ending i'm going to conclude
is best in this video
that is to present my biases from the
start i think the best ending is the age
of the stars the ending in which the
witch ronnie ushers in the age of the
moon stars and chilled night sky
and rest assured i have my reasons for
this in looking at the themes messages
and moral of the story of eldon ring i
think the age of the stars lines up best
when compared with the other two endings
and yes as i said there are four
different variants that make up the
elven lord ending however i think their
differences aren't as relevant as their
overarching similarities when it comes
to determining the best ending the elden
lord endings vary in how we modify the
elden ring to create a new order in game
this means they vary based on which
mending rune we choose to repair the
elden ring with but in all the endings
we are repairing the elden ring in doing
so we are following the guidance of the
two fingers yeah we maybe commit a
cardinal sin by burning the earth tree
but even enya seems pretty okay with
that in following this path we are going
through with the plans and desires of
the greater will an outer god and the
creator and source of the elden beast
and the elden ring
sure we can choose which kind of order
we want to install through the elden
ring one that changes nothing one that
attempts to perfect the previous order
one that brings back death or one that
creates a world of curse modeled after
the omen but all of these options are
just different flavors of an elden
ring-based order the mending runes
represent the visions of the npcs they
come from what each one felt that the
world needed most the vanilla age of
fracture can be seen as the tarnished
player character deciding themselves
that no change is needed just a simple
restart
but as i discussed in my previous video
this ending the age of fracture along
with all of the other elden lord endings
hearkens back to the relinking endings
of dark souls 1 and 3. and in all of
these examples we can see that despite
their desire to leave things open for
the player fromsoft pretty strongly
signifies that these endings are not
right or fully satisfying stagnation and
simply resetting the age are themes
categorically condemned in these games a
reset simple or with an added flare
leads to stagnation and the stifling of
growth an elimination of the chance for
progress and that is what we get with
the elden lord endings even with those
of the mending runes none of their
changes are revolutionary so the order
of the elden ring remains in all of
their new worlds worlds that are subject
to the greater will and in all
likelihood will at some point fail and
return to where this game begins in a
broken world in need of saving in need
of change
so if we rule out the elden lord ending
we are left with two options the age of
the stars and the lord of frenzied flame
let's first see if the ending of
frenzied flame can fit the bill of a
proper from soft end after all you are
very explicitly not following the
greater will's path or the guidance of
the two fingers the lord of frenzy flame
ending is associated with the three
fingers and the mysterious entity behind
them and the frenzy frenzy-based
incantations a possible outer god of
frenzied flame
but wait it sounds like we just switched
out one otherworldly outer god for
another if the elden lord ending was
doing the bidding of the greater will is
this ending just doing the bidding of
the frenzied flame
yeah that's pretty much correct if you
finish hayetz's questline she'll be
nearby when you trigger the frenzy in
flame ending condition i'll also take a
second to note that hayata originally
wanted to become a normal maiden but was
led down the path of the three fingers
unknowingly shiburi grapes were the only
thing that gave her vision which she
thought of as her guiding grace
but when i eat one of those grapes
i can feel a distant light in the back
of my eyes
it will lead me to my true duty
as a finger maiden
eventually she became fully dependent on
them and saw the path of the three
fingers as the only way to become a
maiden she was brought down this path
not as a free agent but as someone
tricked by a greater being
so after being caressed by the three
fingers she has quite a lot to say she
explains that you're now on the path of
the three fingers bidding so if the
frenzied flame guides the three fingers
now you're on its payroll too hayata
also gives the explanation of what the
lord of frenzied flame ending is all
about correcting the mistake of the
greater will melting everything back
into the perfect unity the one great
that existed before the greater will
divided things into souls and separate
living beings this will supposedly do
away with all the anguish sins and
torments of the world things the three
fingers say were started by the greater
will creating divisions and individuals
everything will be better burned into a
supernatural singularity of bliss
so once again we find an ending that is
a manifestation of the will of an outer
god and on top of that it is a rejection
of all the most crucial aspects of human
or tarnished life the frenzy flame sees
despair and sin as blemishes to be
avoided to be subsumed in a blissful
state of non-existence where identity of
the individual is gone
but these experiences are precisely what
make our lives our own we suffer and
struggle and strive to overcome we live
as individuals burdened with these
weights but also as those who can
experience the joy of overcoming them
the lord of frenzy flame ending breaks
from the greater will but only to run
into the more plentiful appendages of
the three fingers and frenzied flame at
the same time it denies the struggles
trials and overcoming that demarcate not
only our lives but also the very core of
from software games
these soulsborne akiro ring games that
from software has been making for over a
decade are notorious for difficulty in
an era of games where most mainstream
titles seek not to emphasize struggle as
part of their experience
miyazaki has stated that a vital part of
fromsoft's game design is hardship
saying in a new yorker interview in our
game specifically hardship is what gives
meaning to the experience so it's not
something we're willing to abandon at
the moment it's our identity
this dedication to hardship is something
that is at the core of the soul's
experience and part of what makes these
games so good philosopher zack jurgensen
wrote about this concept in his phd
dissertation saying that games that are
too easy or require little attention to
rules of skill fail to take full
advantage of what sets video games apart
from other artistic mediums the
potential for a highly immersive
interactive experience easy games negate
the value of working within the video
game medium
difficulty struggle and to quote
miyazaki again the joy that comes from
overcoming hardship are what makes these
games both in story and in gameplay
miyazaki admits that eldon ring is a bit
more approachable on these fronts with
the extra america checkpoints and ashen
spirits and whatnot but it still fully
embraces these principles of difficulty
when we try to find which ending is the
best fit for eldon ring it should be one
that embraces these concepts and it's
clear that the lord of frenzied flame
with its running away from despair does
not and that leaves one final option the
age of the stars and guess what
it embraces these themes of trial and
tribulation with open arms two sets of
open arms in fact
in contrast with the frenzied end the
age of stars has ronnie acknowledge the
individuality of every living being and
every living soul
it accepts and actively takes on fear
doubt and loneliness
it is a path which stretcheth into
darkness
this ending does not shy away from pain
or darkness or the trials of this world
ronnie basically says that this path
will be a difficult one but she
recognizes that a pained life of freedom
is more valuable than a blissful life of
servitude this ending is the best at
fulfilling and realizing the game
direction of miyazaki and from software
it defends the joy that comes from
overcoming hardship
it is also the best at mirroring the
story direction of creating one's own
story like the ending of frenzied flame
the age of stars is a rejection of the
greater will and the established failed
world of the elden ring unlike it though
the age of stars does not simply trade
one outer god for another some have
theorized that the moon or stars stand
as another outer god but i have not seen
any real substantiation of this and
every other outer god we know of is not
simply some elemental entity like the
stars or moon but they are something
more specific whether that be the
greater will the formless mother or the
potentially mistaken rot goddess
this ending is the culmination of
ronnie's plan she was born into a world
that gave her a strict role as empyrean
she was supposed to fall in line and
follow the path laid out by the two
fingers and by extension the greater
will but instead she decided to make her
own path to reject the two fingers and
the world of stagnation found in the
current state of the lands between the
age of the stars is the final step in
that path it is a severance of the old
ways and an allowance for the world to
make its own new way in this way it
lines up with fromsoft's design of
letting the player make their own story
and ronnie is also not someone who asks
for our help at the beginning of the
game she is pursuing her own plan with
no intention of our involvement only
through our meddling and choosing to
help her out for our own in-game benefit
at the start to be fair does she
eventually seek our help the decision is
ours and it is not one which beckons to
some great god but to a dark path guided
by the light of the inanimate stars and
moon
in choosing ronnie's ending and
realizing her path we are taking the
final step in her plan to be free from
some great god directing our life and
the world we may be assisting another
but by doing so out of our own
independent choice and because we do so
to allow the world the chance at its own
story we are choosing the ending most in
line with the game's themes of freedom
and hardship it's also important to note
the contrast between us choosing
ronnie's ending and hayata being strung
along by the three fingers in the lord a
frenzied flame ending
in choosing to make our own story and
embracing the joy of struggle and
hardship the age of the stars is the
ending to elden ring that fits with the
game's themes direction and setting
it is a pristine culmination of the
message of the game forging one's own
path through the hardships of the world
and hey we get an eternal maiden out of
it too
in judging the endings of eldon ring it
is clear as the full moon the age of the
stars is best
of course every player doesn't have to
choose the best ending for their
favorite as i said part of the whole
point of the game is making your own
story so players can choose the ending
that best fits them and or their
playthroughs role play there is merit
and plenty of value to each of the
endings so don't let this video's view
constrain your plane and enjoyment and
of course this is my interpretation
supported by argument you don't have to
agree but if you want to say that you
don't agree you better have some good
reasons if you do why don't you share
them in the comments discuss your views
on the endings and which one might be
best
and if you enjoyed the video subscribe
it lets me know that i should keep doing
more of this kind of content well that's
all i have thank you for watching
you